hey everybody welcome back to pokédex
it's been quite a while since I last
made a video on this game I think it's a
little over two years now but I didn't
actually stop playing this I just
couldn't really make videos of it
because in the meantime I've been doing
something which I'm I'm super happy to
be able to have done and I really really
want to thank the creators of the game
as well because it's been loads of fun
so a little over a year ago I got a
message from Sebastian who's the lead
programmer on the game and I'm saying
lead but really the team is quite small
it's it's mostly him and then Garrett's
doing the arts and then a small group of
collaborators working on different parts
of the game but really it's a two-man
and then core team but I got a message
from him and he was asking me if I
wanted to make scenarios for the game
and for me this was basically a dream
come true because ever since the super
young age have been really into these
kind of things and even though I've
never really made videos like that on my
youtube channel I really love the sort
of management aspects of theme park
games and for me this game and I might
not have the most unbiased opinion about
that but for me this game is really
filling a niche which no game in recent
years has done which is to focus on that
sort of management style very much
classic theme park sim like
rollercoaster tycoon or a theme park
world we've obviously got planet coaster
but it's much more of a sort of digital
sandbox and play tool rather than a
linear sort of gaming experience like
the old games were and then there's
rollercoaster tycoon world I guess but
let's just agree to forget that game so
there really hasn't been much like this
so when he asked me to make the
scenarios I definitely couldn't say
anything else but hell yeah so I've been
working on the scenarios a little over a
year now and they're finally done and
I've made a little over half of the
scenarios which made their way into the
final game and then I've done some stuff
here and there on some of the other ones
so yeah I've seen all of the scenarios
before they gone into the game so I know
what all of the maps looks
look like and I know of course a bunch
of stuff about why I made certain
scenarios in a certain way so I really
love to talk about that as well so
that's something that I'll try it my
best to do wherever I can
during this let's play as well but at
the same time I never actually practiced
too much the actual gameplay
I always tested the levels a little bit
but I've never played a full campaign so
for me this is on one hand very much a
new experience because I'll sort of try
to learn throughout the process as well
well on the other hand I think I have a
super unique sort of perspective as a
person making a let's play of the game
and that most of the levels I'll be
playing I made myself so yeah it'll be
an interesting experience definitely
something very new for me I should also
add it's a bit of a new format for me
since usually I make these kind of
time-lapse videos just for creative
stuff in games but in this case
obviously it's much more gameplay
focused so what I'd like to try and I'd
love to hear your feedback on this as
well because it's a bit of a new thing
for me but what I like to try is to make
it partly management focused gameplay
real-time sort of footage and then
partly the time lapse creative sort of
experience so these videos will probably
be 5050 time lapse versus live gameplay
and we'll see how that works out
but that's I think the best way to go
about doing this because I also don't
have split the different scenarios into
different videos so yeah without further
adieu I think we should go into the
campaign and see what this thing
actually looks like because obviously
you can also play this game sandbox but
for now I really want to show off the
campaign which is also really what the
full release of this game is all about
so we start off with this map over here
it's kind of like a Mario map I suppose
and that you have to unlock new places
and you sort of travel over there but
it's also obscured by all of these
clouds so we don't really see yet where
we're gonna go there's just some names
here in there and slight spoilers but
then aside I I don't even know the order
of
the different campaigns I just sort of
gave them a general idea of which were
they easy in which were the medium in
which were the difficult levels in any
case I think it's probably good to start
off with the tutorial that's not really
a campaign but for those of you who
haven't seen this game before it's
probably a good stunning point
so here's loopy lagoon it's one of the
levels that I made and it was
specifically made to also be the
tutorial level so it's sort of half Li
dun theme park it has some empty areas
over here but then it has all of these
rollercoasters and stuff showing the
game off in the rest of the park so for
those of you who are familiar with the
sort of classic theme park same game
like rollercoaster tycoon or
rollercoaster tycoon world I think this
game in general will be very familiar
terra-tory we have some coasters some
rides some pots it's from an isometric
perspective and everything is placed on
a grid so very much harks back to the
aesthetics of those classic games but at
the same time updating it quite a bit
so obviously the graphics are a bit more
up-to-date and there are some other
changes that I quite like like the the
roller coaster builder even though it
might have a bit of a learning curve
allows for very flexible and smooth
coaster layouts so that's pretty cool in
any case I don't want to dwell too long
in the tutorial so I just want to show
off some things that I think will set
this game apart from some previous games
in the genre and I think most
importantly there's the sort of behind
the scenes aspects of the game now I'm
not gonna do any of the lessons from the
tutorial over here but what the
behind-the-scenes one is basically about
is how you all need to care also for
everything that guests don't see in your
park and you'll have to manage this sort
of logistics behind running a theme park
so over here these paths that we can see
are actually blocked off from guests so
this is for staff only and then over
here there's a staff room as well as a
training room and this over here is a
Depot where all of the trash and
all of the deliveries will be placed so
then we'll need some staff that is going
to bring all of this stuff to this to
the the shops and stars and vending
machines throughout the park but not
just that the game really wants you to
hide these as well as you can so if you
look at a lot of real-life theme parks
especially Disney parks do this really
well for instance all of that sort of
backstage stuff is very well hidden and
invisible for most of the guests and
this is also something that you have to
try your best to do in the game as well
so as we go along making all of these
levels in the scenarios we'll have to
build these sort of back-end systems to
supply all of the deliveries and stuff
while sort of covering it up for the
guests so they can stay in their
immersion of whatever the theme of the
park is that we're working on gonna be
interesting to see how that goes but for
now I think it would be a good idea to
start with a little bit of time-lapse
perhaps over there so we have Maple
Meadows over here a large clearing on
the frontiers of a maple forests the
perfect place to build your first park
from the ground up easygoing guests
relaxed weather what more could you ask
for and then the goal is to have 200
guests in your Park
what's also noteworthy I think is the
optional goal to have like all the the
non optional co-hosts completed by the
end of December year one which basically
means that this game doesn't really have
a time limit and this is something that
I talked about quite a bit with
Sebastian he was really adamant on not
having one since if you look at games
like rollercoaster tycoon
if you didn't make that strict time
limit all of your progress would more or
less be thrown away or you'd have to
very carefully and specifically keep
saves from different times during your
your playthrough of the scenario to sort
of recover what you had but it it's very
much a losing state and he didn't really
want to have that in the game so you can
have all the time that you need to
complete the goals but if you're a
completionist you can always complete
them before a given time so if you
really want a 100% the game you're gonna
have to strictly adhere to these time
rules anyway let's go into maple meadows
and I should also say I think this is
one of these scenarios which Sebastian
made himself so this is not actually one
I made but it's it's quite simple it's
very much just a scenario to come to
terms with how the game works and we
just get an empty field to pretty much
fill in how we like it now I propose
that I start to work on some rides and
some scenery and stalls in a short time
lapse and then afterwards I'll come back
and we can start managing it all right
so now that we're in fast-forward mode
I'm gonna try my best to pay attention
and kind of talk a little bit about what
I decided to do and why so basically my
general idea for this park was to make a
very generic but a rustic looking kind
of family-owned small park so it's not
super well themed and all the scenery
should be quite cheap but at the same
time it sort of has to have a very
charming and classic sort of atmosphere
to it I think major inspiration for me
in this regard is trips trail in Germany
which even though it might sound weird
is one of my most liked top bucket list
parks I would say I really really really
want to go there it's it's something
that not a lot of people share I suppose
because it's not very well known and
it's a very small park and it doesn't
really have any major attractions but
it's it's just it has a supercool
atmosphere and I'd really like to visit
it one day in any case that's the sort
of thing that I'm going here that I'm
going for here I think it also kind of
fits the the layouts of the map and the
sort of limitations that we're getting
in this scenario because for one the map
is just really quite simple it's a very
generic theme that could work for any
kind of temperate region be it somewhere
in Europe or in the US somewhere so I
think it could work like that and also
we don't really get too intense rides in
this scenario we start off with just the
spinning coaster and a kiddie coaster
and obviously we can research some more
stuff but being one of the first parks
we don't really get anything special or
expensive rides or anything like
so I think this stuff that we get here
also more or less fits the theme that
I'm going for
so how I decided and how I decided to
start this out is with a carousel I feel
like in a level like these I I just
always want to start off with a carousel
I always did that in the forest
frontiers in rollercoaster tycoon
I think a lot of people did the same so
it just felt fitting to make that the
first ride and then I also wanted to
make a small food courts and the way I
thought it'd be fun to go about doing
that is to put some buildings for all
the stalls inside so that's kind of
well-hidden and the guests don't have to
see all the backstage areas and then
outside put a little bigger garden kind
of thing I am trying to make a sort of
rustic Germantown look with the scenario
so I think that more or less fits the
theme and it makes for a good entrance
into the rest of the park I think now
this is going to be a very small park so
I'm not going to do too much with this
the map is quite small and then the goal
of the guest count that we need to reach
is also quite small so I'm gonna try and
scale everything accordingly so this is
just a very small food court with two
stalls and a few benches and all of the
paths are also quite narrow and
everything will be built quite close
together I'm not even sure if I'm gonna
really be leading the whole map for this
given how compact everything that I'm
building so far is I don't think I'll be
filling up the entire area that I have
here but yeah I I think that shouldn't
necessarily matter there's always the
idea of you know having to fill in the
entire map of a scenario but if it works
with less it works with less I suppose
oh and obviously I need to build the
toilet as well I think there's a bit of
a it's almost like a running gag where
whenever I do my series in planet
coaster or even back in the roller
coaster tycoon 3 times I always forgot
to build toilets in my park but
obviously it's a bit of a different
ballgame here if
it's a scenario and I do have to
maintain the park from a gameplay
perspective as well so in the next ride
is going to be the teacups just such a
classic ride something that you don't
really want to miss out on when you get
a small park like this and it's always a
nice opportunity to also build a little
building around it very often these
things will have some kind of cover on
top of them and I actually don't know
yet what the climate is like in this
park I suppose that it's quite temperate
and quite easy to work with given that
it's the first scenario but it always
works to put a cover over stuff and have
covered queues like I'm doing over here
and cover up your flat rides and even
these sort of indoor food courts like
anything you can make indoors is just a
big advantage for a theme park and then
I also wanted to spruce up the area with
some path elements and those lights over
there which I really like I think I'll
be using the lights and the flags quite
a lot in different parks it's just a
really easy way to make everything a
little bit more festive and finally
here's the what I think is called the
wipe outs you know it's highly sure but
it's that sort of rotating also very
gentle right that sort of goes up and
down a little bit I think you can really
tell that most of the rides are going to
be quite gentle over here which I think
makes sense I think unless the objective
is to start out with very thrilling
rides because the guests want very
thrilling rides it always makes sense to
build up the gentle rides first because
they are sort of a first necessity and
if you've got a few of those you can
move to making the more thrill demanding
guests happy but I think from a
realistic standpoint getting the gentle
rides in first is a decent strategy
although from a game perspective it
might not be the best because you can't
ask for a lot of money for those in any
case I'm I'm trying to balance out these
two worlds of realism and gameplay over
here so yeah that's basically why I did
it this way but yeah that's it for this
time-lapse so I'll go back into the real
time ports and show you around a little
bit all right so here we have a nice
little start to the park and I could see
the crates are already being delivered
so that's quite good one of the biggest
advantages I think of this game is that
you can actually pause the game while
you're building stuff and that's not
really true for all of the games in the
genre I think some of the past ones sort
of try to keep the time restriction by
also not allowing you to build when the
game is paused but in this case you
don't really have a limit in terms of
your your final goal for when you can
achieve it so you could pretty much
pause the game whenever you want to so I
think it'd be a good idea to just pause
the game when I'm doing some of the
detailed scenery but then when we're
actually working on the park I think we
can run it in the background it looks a
bit nicer as well now what I'm getting
so far I think it would be so I'm not
actually sure what what's better here if
I should make the park entirely free and
then raise the prices of the rides as
much as possible or if I should just do
both at the same time I really sort of
have to get a feeling for the sort of
financial picture of the game that said
I know Sebastian told me one day that
you can pretty much raise your prices to
1.5 times the excitement rating divided
by ten so that's not actually too much
of a mathematical calculation there so
it means that this should theoretically
be allowed to go to three point five in
terms of how much the ride costs so I'm
gonna try that see if that actually
works yeah more or less because half of
this would be eleven point five and then
if you add to that and that's it's
pretty much three point five we'll see
if that works then for the teacups
okay so okay not quite for oh but I'm
gonna ask for for it anyway let's see if
people want to pay that money and then
for this one oh gosh you can raise the
price quite a bit on this one I'm gonna
start with five and see how the people
respond to that so yeah I really need I
really still need to get a feeling for
it on the other hand I don't think
this scenario will punish me too much
for having sort of low prices where
people are still willing to pay more of
it but probably then I'll come into play
in some of the later scenarios
definitely seems like we need to build
some more intense rides and speaking of
that there isn't really anything super
intense in here we've got a spinning
coaster but really that's not all that
intense either I'm not sure okay so this
would be intensity of three point four
or thirty four actually and this is 32
so it's not that much of a difference so
if I want to have an intense ride I
think I should really go for a spinning
coaster somewhere and I don't know what
the pre builds versions of these are
have I built this one day before because
I don't know I don't remember I've had
this game for too long but yeah it would
be nice to probably build a small
spinning coaster somewhere I'm feeling
like I could sort of take a corner over
here to do that
good and I should probably hire a
research team as well the way that it
works over here is you can hire multiple
teams I believe if you can and I think
that's true for actually it would be
highly expensive but you can hire teams
and you can basically have them work on
certain types of rides so in this case I
love them to ride to work on thrill
rides and then you can give them a
monthly budgets I think $200 is just
about fine means that I'll get a ride
eventually but I'm not losing too much
of my money every month
speaking of losing money I am losing
money at the moment which is a bit
unfortunate not entirely sure where this
is happening so yeah lots of
construction in the last month but then
my operation is also not that great and
a lot of that is building maintenance I
actually didn't think about that in any
case I think it'd be interesting to
start a little coaster over here and see
how that goes all right so I'm gonna try
to keep an eye on realism here so that
means partly I'm gonna try to have some
employee paths and backstage area for
this coaster
but also I'm trying to make it in a
sense that it realistically could be
built by the company that builds them in
real life
so this coaster in game is based on the
real-life girl our spinning coaster made
by a German company and what's fairly
typical about it is that the the seats
on the coaster face each other so where
with most spinning coasters you're kind
of sitting toward the outside here you
can actually see the people who are
riding it together with you which is
kind of funny but not too important when
thinking about the layouts basically
these coasters often have very curvy
layouts with lots of transitions and
unlike very fair ground-type spinning
coasters these ones do you have banked
curves and hurt actually quite smooth so
that's also the type of layout that I'm
trying to build and realistically also
it's not even really spinning
that's much since you don't have those
tights twists and turns which some of
these things do feature but in this case
I thought it would be more fitting to
just go with a sort of standard family
type kind of a spinning coaster so it
doesn't really do too much but at least
it's realistically smooth to the degree
I suppose what I should also note is
that there's lots of block breaks in the
layouts which is basically because you
can't really realistically put many
trains in the station you need those
block breaks to divide the coaster into
blocks and every train or every little
car can really only occupy one block at
a time so all of these blocks just allow
for more cars on the track and that's
also why there's lots of parts in the
middle of the track where just sort of
stops for a second goes into a break and
then it's done speaking of done by the
way the layout is basically done at this
point I tried to do this quite quickly
and at this point it is time to move
into the scenery parts of the experience
I just decided to make the colors of the
track red and the colors of the supports
Brown which is very sort of standard
generic rustic color scheme that I think
fits the coaster quite a bit I decided
to add a small transfer track
over here although I do realize this is
not a typical the spinning coaster
transfer track I believe usually these
things have more of a switch track kind
of mechanism but I didn't really have
the skills or the time or not actually
more or less also space to do that kind
of thing so I decided to just quickly do
it like this but that said if anybody
you know if you have any feedback on how
I'm building stuff or how I could make
it better or more realistic of course by
all means please comments and tell me
about anything that I'm doing poorly and
I should improve on because that's
honestly also what I need to improve
now the scenery for this coaster is
really just quite simple a bunch of
foliage and then a simple station I
don't go too far on the theming lots of
these sort of small family-owned rustic
charming parks tend to not really put
too much scenery behind well the the
area is where you can directly see it
from the paths so even if they'll have
very charming and well themed
restaurants and stations and stuff the
rites themselves are typically not that
themed so just a bit of foliage here and
there [ __ ] more or less do the trick I
think and then there's a nice little
area where the path is sort of comes out
and interacts with the coaster as it
goes through the helix over there as for
the station I decided to just make it a
very simple sort of low-key station I
think this is something that also came
to mind during a geek ism's let's play
of Architects which I wholeheartedly
recommend by the way he's doing a great
let's play of this game and I'm super
happy to see him play some of the
scenarios that I made and see his
reaction to it but something he also
noted is you know sometimes you just
need to make some slightly ugly and
boring buildings because realistically
that's just what a lot of theme parks
will build especially if they don't have
the budget to do much more than that and
I'm sure that the park that I'm building
over here would pretty much be the same
way so the station is just quite simple
and functional in any case with that
said it is time to move back and see how
the coaster is doing
Oh God what's quite embarrassing is that
I didn't actually finish the track
correctly because it still has like
missing track pieces which it doesn't
like so I'm gonna have to remove some of
these and I think not actually there's
still something in there isn't there
God how am I gonna get there actually
gonna have to remove some of this yeah
there we go so there's still that track
piece of there and now I should be able
to connect this yeah there we go so I
suppose I'm gonna have to build a
different coaster to actually finish the
end of that but let me take this
opportunity to fix some other stuff so
this should be 15 kilometres an hour and
I want to trim this but only to 20 just
to make sure that it's gonna make the
next one because it's actually
dangerously slow over here and I'll trim
this one too right now so we can test
this now and pretty much run the coaster
but before I do that or actually wow I
do that I suppose I'm gonna just build
some new ones I wonder if that does add
to my monthly costs so you know what I
should maybe do maybe I should try and
build a fence as though it were a door
of this building I mean that doesn't
quite work but I think the idea is
decent I should probably look for some
better fences to put in there but um
yeah it might be a good idea to not just
put coaster track everywhere because
that stuff is it's kind of expensive and
might become a lot of efforts to do that
every time so for now I think I'm just
gonna put this down here as a sort of
door mechanism that more or less works
but I don't know I'm gonna have to
consider that actually for now though
the coaster seems to be working alright
although it is not getting stuck in
place and some wonder if I can good
block breaks
maybe I'll just I'll replace this one
with block brakes let me try that I
don't know if it's a good idea but I
think it won't get stuck on there
because there is a curve after it but
yeah I just want to try it I just want
to make sure that I have more space for
the car so sort of we go around because
we do block breaks like this you always
need to make sure that you've got some
space left so they don't have to stop on
every single block break which if you've
ever been on a coaster like this it is
really annoying if the car stops on
every block breaks so I would like to
actually defend against that so it seems
like everything is clear and they are
running pretty well yep
every time one of the bug breaks is
cleared so that's really good actually
so we can pretty much just keep it up
like this would like to recolor maybe
the cars because they look a bit weird
at the moments of things just some dark
rustic wood colour should work there we
go and let's open it up now I didn't
actually think about a name but I'll
just I'll just put the the first thing
that comes to mind every time for the
rides for some reason this thing reminds
me of a ladybug I guess it could be I
don't know
let's go for it so there we go ladybug
is open I think the rest is fine
although that said there is some vomits
on the paths and as you can see if the
people walk through it they just end up
spreading all of the vomits so I
definitely want to hire another janitor
to keep everything clean looks like over
here it's all fine no vandals or
anything which is also really good
because vandals tend to destroy pretty
much everything in this game and I need
to hook up the queue so I should not
forget that let's see I want to wait
that's not what I tried to do I need to
copy this Kali there we go I think I'm
just gonna do it like this for
yeah for time or rather for space-saving
sake and see how people like the ride
and there we go
looks to me like a bunch of happy guests
unfortunately I forgot to raise the
price though so I'm gonna have to raise
that too I think
650 they'll be able to at least pay this
amount and I'm pretty sure I can go over
there as well
if anybody who's watching this is a pro
at this game please let me know how much
I can like try to push these prices I
know you can pretty much just listen to
the guests and what they are saying
about it but I don't really want to rely
on that although I can eventually if I
want to but yeah I think this pretty
much works out and there we go it
doesn't crash it doesn't get stuck
anywhere and it looks pretty neat I
think it fits into the part quite well
now I think for the future expansions I
don't to move over here because I'm
already at 130 guests and I just need to
get 200 and it's already October so I
don't think I'll make the optional goal
then again I don't really feel the need
to but I will try to fill in this area
with some different rides and it's a
good thing that I've got the enterprise
being researched at them or actually
completed and I can get some go cards
that said I'm not sure if I have enough
time to actually get this but that would
be quite nice and I'm making money it's
just a very small amount of money but
I'm not losing money anymore so that's
pretty good technically I'm running in
profits so let's just keep going and see
what we can make of it alright here we
are in the last time lap section for
today and I'll more or less be finishing
the entire park I think I've got a
pretty good base a pretty good
foundation for the park with what I have
right now and just a little bit more of
scenery and some flat rides and a little
kiddie coaster at the end should more or
less finish it up I do realize that I'm
already pretty much on routes to
finishing the park when it comes to
reaching 200 guests I'm pretty sure if I
just leave it running now I am gonna be
able to reach that goal
that said I wanted to pause the game
just to make sure that I had enough time
before I finished the scenario to work
on some more scenery and make this into
a neat little park so my first idea was
to put a topspin over here since I
really didn't have a super-intense right
yet the spinning coaster didn't turn out
as intense as I hoped so this should
more or less fix that issue I really
like these rides I think they're one of
the best flat rides the place and
they're always very much a fun flat ride
to sort of try to feature into the
scenery of the park when it comes to
flat rides not all of them tend to
interact so much with the scenery of the
park a lot of flat rides are just kind
of very generic maybe they have their
own little theming or color scheme that
fits the park but it's not like you
really have to integrate them into the
surrounding scenery and with top spins
you very often see that they kind of get
their own pedestal almost like they're a
sort of show to watch and you can build
the paths around them in such a sense
that people can stand or sit around them
and see the the cycle go as a lot of
people will not want to ride a Top Spin
either because they are too afraid or
because those things just make you super
nauseous so it's always a great flat
ride to build some scenery around and
build something around it so that people
can sit down and have a look at it even
if they're not writing it themselves so
one of my favorite flat rides also from
an in-game perspective it's one of the
cheapest like intense things that you
can place for a thrill ride it's
honestly quite good and it should more
or less make all of the thrill-seeking
guests pretty happy now I moved into the
back of the park to finish on the last
parts and the idea was you know this is
a park that sort of grows over time so
the area closest to the entrance would
be the oldest and this area which is
much further from the entrance I wanted
to make it a little bit different from
the rest of the park to kind of make it
look as if it's more of a recent
expansion maybe not super reasons but at
the very least make it slightly
different so going for some different
pavements and pavements colors here and
generally also a little bit more of an
expensive look to it I think so
I'll be getting to that in a second but
I decided to put a building at the end
of this little street right in front of
this small square with the pavilion in
the middle which is going to be the new
food courts and it's going to look quite
a bit more expensive and a bit nicer
than the existing food court that we
have at the start of the park then
there's also a bunch of flat rides I
decided to fit like a sort of parameter
path to build with him to give myself a
bit more of a challenge and to have that
sort of backstage area in hindsight I
really don't think I'll be doing that
for all of the parks since this made
things quite a bit more difficult and
from a gameplay perspective it was kind
of annoying since a lot of employees
just ended up working there but for the
sort of park layouts it was interesting
to have this limitations I myself so
everything had to be quite compact so
even though I'm putting a pretty good
amount of flat rides here and also a
small roller coaster everything has to
be really close together and I think
that resulted in a pretty good realistic
layout for this area anyway so I placed
a enterprise and twister ride and this
is the food courts building so as you
can see it's quite a bit more
extravagant than the existing old wooden
shed that functioned as a food court and
I was sort of debating whether I wanted
to do this or not but I ended up doing
it anyway because I couldn't stop myself
I just built this little Tower to make
the building look a little bit nicer it
doesn't really have a function it's
really just scenery and it's almost like
disney-esque scenery but I really wanted
to try some of these pieces also because
I haven't played with some of these
scenery elements very much yet and a lot
of these new elements like the sort of
stepwise gable pieces that I'm using for
the front of the facade and the rooftop
spire these are all new scenery pieces
or at least relatively new from one of
the newest Park attacked updates so I
haven't had time to try them yet so this
building was more or less also just a
quick try to see how some of the new
pieces are and I'm super glad with it
actually I think a spire piece
is a rooftop piece which the game has
been missing for quite a while too so to
see something like that in the game now
is super cool anyway there's the small
kiddie coaster it's not much but I need
you sign it it would pretty much fit
very neatly into the design of the park
and it's very loosely themed as well but
I think just putting an airplane or some
kind of prop in the middle of the kiddie
coaster seems to be quite a theme for a
lot of theme parks especially theme
parks like this
I think the the best example that I've
ever been on is probably the dog for its
coaster in Denmark you can look this up
by the way this is a real thing in a
park called bonbon lund they have a
kiddie coaster with a dog [ __ ] right
in the middle of the coaster and yes
this is a pg-13 video so I suppose I
have one slur that I can use per video
anyway so yeah that's one of the
weirdest examples but usually they do
this with some kind of other objects I
know in wallaby Holland they just have a
little train in the middle of the kiddie
coaster track anyway that's something
you can always do with a kiddie coaster
I think just put some kind of objects in
the middle and call out the theme and
with that said this area is more or less
finished I decided to add some more
foliage to it keeping it quite small and
a little bit smaller than the rest of
the park because it would be sort of
newer parts of the park but aside from
that there's not too much to really say
about it just put some shrubs and trees
everywhere and everything looks a little
bit nicer I suppose
anyway with that said we've come at the
end of the time-lapse so let's jump back
into real time and see what the park
looks like well ladies and gentlemen we
did it although it went a little bit
quicker than I expected so I wasn't on
time for the confetti and the grant
announcements but I've got 200 guests in
my park so we're pretty much all done
out here that said of course the
time-lapse doesn't really show off the
park as much as a bit of a real-time
overview would I suppose so yeah the
what the final Park ended up looking
like it's quite simple and I really
didn't end up using all of the space
that I have there
is still a bit of empty space left over
here but overall I'm really happy with
it
actually there's a bunch to improve
especially from a gameplay perspective
like this entire sort of employee path
alongside the outskirts of the park wow
it would technically make sense if it
were coming from a realistic standpoint
it doesn't really help I would probably
be better off connecting that to a path
like right around over here especially
so all the employees don't end up
walking around here but that aside I'm
yeah I'm pretty happy with it and
actually quite like the layouts of the
spinning coaster I wasn't so sure in the
beginning but it's sort of grown on me
over time so yeah I'm actually quite
glad with how that turned out overall
it's more or less what I was going for I
suppose a very rustic family-oriented
Park with just a few rides probably sort
of in its beginning stages the idea was
also to partly you know make it like
this area is a little bit older and this
area is a little bit newer and I think
overall that sort of makes sense so yeah
I'm quite happy with it and I think I've
got some stuff to take with me in the
next scenario I do want to try to go for
a slightly different style in every
scenario that I build just to keep it a
bit challenging for myself and to see
how I can sort of fit the build into the
terrain that the scenario gives you I
also love how you can tell then even
after a little bit of letting the game
play I've got so many more guests than
2-hundred so the whole strategy of like
putting the game on pause and then
unpause it once everything is built and
just letting the guests flow it actually
works quite well although I do have to
say I should probably seem a little bit
less for the upcoming scenarios because
I ran out of money quite quickly and
then and I ended up taking a loan which
might not be too bad but when the
scenarios get harder I should really try
not to rely on that anyway I believe if
I now click on anyway that's fine but a
good message actually if I now click on
quits and get out of here I think I end
up in the main screen I should be
getting a bit of a note
ah there we go all right awesome so then
we get a little trophy which is just
this sort of special building which sort
of drops down on the map to let you know
that you've completed this scenario and
I think you also get the blueprints so
this will also just well make the entire
world map a little bit of a happier
place with all these trophies showing
you what you've done already and for me
it was actually a lot of fun because at
some point I was asked if I could make
the maps in such a way that there would
be a sort of trophy to work with or
otherwise go back to the maps which
didn't have a building which could work
as a trophy and add them in there so for
me being a big fan of wienies I was
actually a lot of fun so I'm actually
kind of curious to see what all the
trophies will look like in the entire
world map since even though I've made
the majority of them I haven't quite
seen them on the world map yet anyway
the next scenario is to new airfield
I guess you pronounce it this way which
is a small abandoned airfield but that
is something for the next episode I hope
you guys like this episode let me know
what you think of the format's and what
you think of the game of course and I
will hopefully see you guys next time
bye bye